my favorites have it we may need to eat
twice as much absolute man that don't do
it you really actually only need about
200 extra calories a day over a normal
American diet and that's assuming that
you're starting pregnancy at a normal
weight sex during pregnancy hurts the
baby
well cocoa butter prevents stretch marks
this is a myth I'm Laura Riley I'm a
high risk OB at New York Presbyterian
Hospital Weill Cornell I'm Deena Goffman
I'm a high risk OB at New York
Presbyterian Columbia it's okay to drink
a glass of wine when you're pregnant
we know that the recommendation in
pregnancy is that you really should not
consume any alcohol unfortunately there
is no safe amount of alcohol nor a safe
time in pregnancy when we can be sure
that alcohol won't affect a developing
fetus also I think it's important to add
that we don't think it's safe to drink
while you're breastfeeding either
because the alcohol does get into breast
milk and as dr. Kaufman said we don't
know what the safe amount is and that
safe amount may actually change for
different women your belly reveals the
baby's gender we certainly hear patients
coming in to see us and having heard or
having family members say that they can
tell whether you're having a boy or a
girl based on how the woman's belly
looks and we know that there is
absolutely no evidence that the shape of
your belly can tell us this type of
information the other myth that goes
along with gender I think is the heart
rates high or low but in patients always
say that you know they come in
oh it's 160 it must be a girl like know
if it's 160 it means the kids moving a
lot and if it's sleeping it's gonna be
120 so it doesn't tell you whether it's
a girl
boy cocoa butter prevents stretch marks
this is a myth
while cocoa butter is something that
many patients like to use we don't have
any evidence that that cocoa butter or
anything else that we can recommend will
prevent stretch marks it's probably
genetic and essentially if you gain too
much weight in one spot ie your
pregnancy gets really big you're more
likely to get stretch marks
unfortunately but it's not we're
spending a ton of money on expensive
creams because it's not gonna work
that was cheery it can give a cold to
your developing baby this is a complete
myth your baby is not gonna get the cold
although your baby can get sick if you
get something like the flu which is why
we tell you to get a flu shot to prevent
your baby from getting really sick there
are some illnesses that you can transfer
to your baby but probably not a cold I
think people get the cold and the flu
confused which is which is unfortunate
because the flu can make it really sick
and pregnancy what you eat during
pregnancy can influence the babies
palate I don't think there is a shred of
evidence to support that I think that
what you eat during pregnancy is
important because it does sort of you
know set your baby off to a good start
in terms of its overall nutrition and
good health but it's probably not going
to change the biggest palate we always
talk about nutrition and food choices
and healthy weight gain which really can
have long-term impact on your baby's
development but not specifically the
palate or what they have it tastes for
pregnant women shouldn't drink coffee
that's something you can drink coffee
this is one where moderation is is the
most important thing in the first
trimester having excessive amounts of
coffee have been associated with a
higher risk of miscarriage once that
first trimester is over should you go
crazy with the coffee probably not but
it's not going to harm anything pregnant
women shouldn't eat hotdogs so this is a
myth
I think the concern with hotdogs are a
few you want to make sure that they are
well
to avoid infection risk and there used
to be a fair amount of conversation
about the amount of nitrites and hotdogs
but I think the evidence suggests that
unless you're eating really excessive
amounts of hotdogs that it's probably
okay to enjoy one I think there are
probably things better than hot dogs to
eat nutritionally but I think if people
enjoy one once in a while I don't have a
problem with it
you're not way nicer than is I'm not
your wife anybody's eating hot dogs
frankly but you know you can have one in
in pregnancy but I think it's really
important to make sure that it's cooked
because the concern about Listeria is a
real concern so that includes the hot
dogs the unpasteurized cheeses the deli
needs all of those things are things
that we worry about so I think you know
yeah it's a myth that you can't eat hot
dogs but you should be certain well
pregnant women shouldn't eat smoked
salmon that's a myth
you can eat smoked salmon if you like it
I'm not a lover of salmon so I love it
you can eat smoked salmon this gets into
concerns around fish consumption in
pregnancy which is a huge topic and we
talk to our patients about the risk of
various types of fish so we want to
avoid fish with high mercury content so
typically that would be avoiding
excessive tuna choosing chunk light and
tuna and also limiting the number of
cans of tuna in a week there is also
some concern about some of these oily
fish I guess about the potential for
toxins and so I would say salmon in
general may fall into that category but
smoked salmon I think is safe for a
pregnant woman to eat the whole fish
story is a little blown out of
proportion and I think people get really
crazy about this whole mercury thing I
would say it's important to also
recognize though that fish has great
nutritional value to it that pregnant
renamed
and babies need and want so it is
unfortunate that somehow the fish story
has you know resulted in people thinking
I can't have any fish it's really the
large sake fishes where you're worried
about the mercury but then don't forget
that something like salmon is gonna give
you the DHA s which you want pregnant
women shouldn't pet cat this is a myth
this would be terrible if all pregnant
women in the world couldn't pet their
pets their cats there is a concern with
pregnant women caring for cats in terms
of the litter box and really the risk is
toxoplasmosis and the risk of exposure
isn't with interacting with your cat but
with changing a dirty litter box it is
actually fairly rare in the US for women
to come into contact with toxoplasmosis
the more important thing about sort of
the cat story is everyone worries about
the cat and the kitty litter the most
common exposure that women get to
toxoplasmosis is actually not the cat or
the litter even it's not washing your
garden vegetables because it's the cat
that has the toxin that poops in your
garden and then you pick that up and eat
it because you don't wash it or whatever
so gardening without gloves are things
that we tell pregnant women to avoid
because of that particular infection the
cats got a bad rap unfortunately
pregnant women shouldn't fly total myths
get on the plane have a good time that
said there are a few things to think
about when flying I think one of the
major issues is that pregnant women are
at increased risk for getting a blood
clot either in their leg or their lungs
when you fly the air is dry you're also
more likely just to be sitting for a
prolonged period of time and that just
ain't further increases your risk for
getting a blood clot so I always tell
pregnant women and be happy go ahead go
on those you know trips but you should
hydrate before you go you should wear
support hose or at least like you know
running tights or something that gives
you a little bit of support in your leg
you should get up and walk around every
hour or so people worry about the air
pressure which makes some sense because
it's a pressurized cabin that doesn't do
anything you're not gonna break your
water and they also worry about going
through the screener right everybody's
worried about the radiation going
through the screener but in fact the
radiation exposure is actually higher
when you're in the sky in the plane than
it is when you're walking quickly
through those through the security
exercise during pregnancy can strangle
the baby this is a myth exercise is
actually strongly recommended during
pregnancy all of our professional
organizations all of us as providers
talk to patients about maintaining
physical activity maintaining exercise
throughout the pregnancy really unless
there's a medical situation that comes
up that changes those recommendations so
exercise is not dangerous and in fact
the opposite it's really important I
think also this whole strangling thing
comes from this crazy nonsense that if
you get yourself into certain yoga
positions your baby can't ranks triangle
itself you don't have any control over
the position your baby gets into the
baby is floating in a pool of water and
it doesn't matter whether you're doing a
headstand or you're just like chilling
sex during pregnancy hurts the baby well
that's a big myth and it also helps to
understand sort of the anatomy a little
bit I think this is where patients get a
little bit confused the baby is floating
inside a pool of water big balloon bag
and that balloon bag is surrounded by
thick muscle which is the uterus
surrounds the entire bag and has
actually a thicker portion at the bottom
so there's just no way that sex is gonna
get even near the baby dyeing your hair
is harmful for the baby this is another
big myth and we get phone calls about it
lots of questions there is no evidence
and again we keep coming back to
evidence because it's what we look to as
your physicians and there really is no
evidence out there that's things that we
use for hair dyeing reach the baby or
have the potential to cause harm the
other thing about the hair dye frankly I
tell people it's gonna make you feel
better that's really important because
for a lot of us how we look and how we
present ourselves really has a lot to do
with our psychological state and you
want that to be as healthy as possible
during pregnancy there are simple tricks
to overcome morning sickness I think
that that's a myth in the sense that
none of those things we're probably
simple but I think there are ways to
sort of decrease the painfulness of
morning sickness the first thing is is
that the morning sickness can last all
days so the whole morning thing is a
myth in of itself but that said some of
the things that you can do to help it
try and start the day with something
really simple like soda crackers the
minute you get out of bed saltines
something really bland stay away from
the smells the smells are gonna make you
sicker I think the biggest thing that
I've learned over the course of my
career and had personal involvement with
this one is we tell people to stay
hydrated and so they go after the water
bottle and stay away from the water the
water makes you sick I don't understand
it but it makes you sick so what I tell
patients is put everything over crushed
ice that way you'll get the water but
you're not actually drinking it and
gulping air as you're drinking out of a
water bottle the things that I would put
over ice I would say lemonade ginger ale
letting some of the fizz out will help
as well
lemon popsicles lemon slush lemon
Italian ice the reason I say lemon is
because lemon helps cut the nausea as
well I think the other critical thing
for morning sickness is it's important
to go out every day I think sometimes
what happens is you feel that nauseous
then you feel worse then you start to
feel depressed and then you can't get
yourself moving because you're tired and
that's the worst thing you can do is to
sort of give into it I think it's
important to get outside walk around
even if it's just down the block and
back c-sections are always necessary for
breech birth
so this is a myth although I think most
of us think c-sections are the most
common and the safest way to deliver a
singleton so a single baby in labor
especially at term so there are
certainly situations that we need to be
able to individualize for often we'll
talk to patients with twins if the
second twin is breech that may be a
great option for them and I think there
are rare situations where a woman comes
in in labor where we may recommend
and/or support a vaginal breech delivery
for a singleton I think in order to
support a vaginal breech delivery you
need to have a provider who has
experience doing that and you know the
reality is is that in the US the number
of providers that are able to do this
safely is definitely diminishing almost
to none I think the other option though
which I think we should put out there on
the table is a version which is if you
know the baby is breech and you're at
term is coming in for a procedure where
we under ultrasound guidance turn the
baby to head down if you sit all day
you'll have a breech baby total myth if
you sit all day you'll gain a lot of
weight and you'll have back pain but
your baby will do whatever your baby is
going to do most babies are not breach
at full term so only about like three
percent of babies are gonna be breach at
full truck those babies are gonna turn
multiple times until they get to around
36 or 37 weeks and so it has nothing to
do with whether you're running a
marathon or you're sitting on the bottom
pregnant women should sleep on their
left side I think the pregnant women
should sleep how they're comfortable
although we know that women as they get
more pregnant into the second and
certainly in the third trimester may not
be able to sleep flat on their back and
that's because as the pregnancy grows
the fetus grows the uterus grows the
weight that the uterus will put on your
blood vessels and some other structures
may make that really uncomfortable and
not ideal for the baby so women
on their left side they can sleep on
their right side they can sleep on their
back tilt it a little bit but um we
usually aren't so strict as to say left
side only
I think people worry that oh my gosh I
woke up and I'm flat on my back did I
kill my baby didn't kill your baby
if you sleep you know flat on your back
is dr. Kaufman said the structure we're
most worried about is the inferior vena
cava so it's this big blood vessel
bringing blood back up to your heart in
your head and most people are gonna get
really nauseous right and lightheaded
and feel weird and so you'll naturally
turn you don't have to weak yourself up
to do it your hair and skin look better
when you're pregnant
I wish your might look better I guess
your skin probably won't necessarily
look better some women say they glow I
think that they're dreaming
unfortunately the high progesterone
levels that you get when you're pregnant
to support the pregnancy actually can
really bring out a key that you haven't
seen since you were 13 years old and all
the expensive creams in the world are
not gonna fix that so I wouldn't suggest
that you spend your money on it pregnant
women get flexible you know we recognize
there are lots of changes going on in
women's bodies when they're pregnant but
I wouldn't say that getting flexible is
one of them there are certain things
that happen in terms of your posture how
you stand and definitely some relaxation
of different parts of your body to
prepare your pelvis to be able to have a
vaginal birth but I don't think that
sort of traditional flexibility is what
we typically see eating spicy foods will
induce labor huh so if this were true
that would be wonderful because we could
help women um you know induce labor when
we wanted to unfortunately we haven't
been able to come up with any particular
food or physical activity or drink or
supplement that actually can induce
labor we have medications to use to
induce labor but as far as we've been
able to tell there's no evidence that
any of those
things that women may want to try
actually will be effective I think
people are just looking for something to
get out of Dodge at 40 weeks which I can
totally relate to it's probably not
gonna hurt the spicy food probably won't
hurt you can do whatever you want but
your baby's in charge just remember that
yoga can induce labor we think there are
a lot of benefits to potentially doing
yoga and participating in pregnancy but
inducing labor isn't one of them
certainly more women are using yoga
which may help with relaxation may help
with stress relief may help it's
stretching and so I think there are a
lot of reasons why yoga may be a great
thing to participate in but there's no
evidence but it induces if only Logan
makes Labor's smoother I think overall
exercise probably gives you a better
labor in the sense that it is usually
more efficient but Yoga itself not
necessarily making it smoother there are
some things about yoga that are similar
to other labor preparation or childbirth
preparation things right breathing
mindfulness I think are similar to some
childbirth preparation things so I think
in that sense some of those things may
help you to be more centered be able to
focus be able to use some of those
strategies to help but certainly not
make labor itself natural births are
better this is a myth
there are certainly women
spend time thinking about what they like
their birth experience to be like and I
think for some women natural birth and
the way we think about that is usually
birth without pain medication and for
some women this may be a wonderful
experience but we all know that we need
to individualize the care for our
patients and for many women a natural
birth may not be better there may be
real medical benefits depending on the
situation and underlying condition to
having pain medication to having an
epidural I'm a huge fan of natural
childbirth I have to say but I do think
that it takes some preparation and I
think it takes me mental preparation and
I think that it's not better or worse I
also think that there's there is another
myth associated with natural childbirth
which is that if you're induced you have
to have anesthesia because the pain is
worse the pain is bad whether we give
you the contractions or your kid gives
you the contractions or it happens
naturally whatever it's painful and some
people can cope better because they
practice mindfulness or hypnobirthing or
whatever and then sometimes people can
just go better because it's faster but
again I think it's all about everybody
how it can make their own new birth
choices there I love this one there are
ways to predict your exact due date when
we give you your due date it's plus or
minus two weeks and the reason is
because your kids in charge of which go
into labor
we are not though I have to say are much
more precise and knowing what your dates
are than we used to be because we use
ultrasound early early ultrasound so
much more frequently obviously there's
those people who have done IVF you know
even more but again even if you know
when it all started you do not know when
it will all end because the person who
knows that is your baby
and
can't at the moment talk to that person